[Musique]
à
c
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce second
épisode de mode d'emploi le magazine qui
vous donne les clés pour construire
votre projet professionnel pour
apprendre un métier différents cursus
sont possibles parmi eux il existe une
alternative encore sous-estimé en france
incontournable cette méthode
d'enseignement a volé la vedette aux
filières générales en suisse comme en
allemagne lumière sur l'apprentissage
apparu en france au moyen âge à l'époque
des corporations
l'apprentissage s'est ensuite répandue
au début du xviiie siècle au travers du
compagnonnage
ce n'est qu'en 1971 qu'il devient une
cuillère d'éducation valorisé par un
diplôme pour s'ouvrir aux diplômes de
l'enseignement supérieur une dizaine
d'années plus tard le concept un contrat
ouvert aux jeunes de 15 à 30 ans
alternant des périodes d'études et de
travail en entreprise avec rémunération
à la clé au sommaire de ce magazine nous
verrons pourquoi l'apprentissage peut
être la solution idéale dans certains
métiers à travers la famille mille voix
et pour entrevoir les perspectives
qu'offre cette formule nous suivrons
sabine barre et spécialiste en la
matière qui en a fait son cheval de
bataille
enfin nous rencontrerons l'entreprise
thyssenkrupp matérialise france qui a
compris tout l'intérêt de former des
collaborateurs sur mesure grâce à cette
transmission de savoir
il y a cinq ans 54 mille emplois étaient
non pourvus dans les métiers de
l'hôtellerie restauration un secteur où
il est essentiel d'avoir une expérience
terrain justin nous prouve qu'on peut
être à la fois au four et au moulin de
retrouver la famille mille voix à chacun
son métier avec l'artisanat
[Musique]
bah tiens voilà ma justin qui vient nous
annoncer qu'elle a choisi son futur
métier comment tu sais vous imaginez
haute écoute jamais cuisinière comme moi
bah oui tu m'a un peu transmis son amour
de la cuisine et des bons petits plats
et moi des bons produits non qui fait le
marché les ché en tout cas trouve toi un
commis aussi dynamique et efficace que
toi oui parce que c'est un secteur très
difficile de la restauration non c'est
un métier de passionnés
quand on aime on compte pas mais tu as
intérêt à être bonne si tu veux gagner
correctement t'habilles tu sais des
clients heureux c'est une bonne
récompense
oui c'est vrai il ya des endroits on
n'est pas tous les jours encourager un
mois les virements finir je t'invite en
restant génial non mais qui fait la
quiche alors c'est toi
[Musique]
avec choisir l'artisanat poulet faire
cette année on enregistre 9369 apprentis
dans les yvelines
des effectifs qui progresse dans les
niveaux post bac mais qui décline dans
les niveaux infra bac
l'objectif de la région ile-de-france
pour 2021 est de taille atteindre les
5000 apprentis soit 25% de plus pour
répondre à cette demande de nouveaux
postes ont été créés regardez ce
portrait de sabine barre et
développeuses de l'apprentissage
[Musique]
je suis sabine barré développeurs de
l'apprentissage territoriales sur le sud
yvelines
mon combat c'est de faire avancer
l'apprentissage de faire évoluer les
mentalités de redorer l'image de
l'apprentissage
moi j'en parle pas trop le contrat de
proust et formation continue alors que
la princesse les formations initiales le
développeur de l'apprentissage
territoriales c'est un poste qui est
prise en charge par le conseil régional
ile de france il y en a deux par
département dans toute l'île de france
et qui est porté par une mission locale
donc moi en l'occurrence la mission
locale de saint quentin en yvelines qui
porte mon poste je pars du de réunion
que j'organise sur le territoire avec
tous les partenaires dont notamment les
quatre cio du territoire les quatre
missions locales
la mission de lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire et de l'autre côté les cff
on va faire des actions aussi
directement auprès des jeunes donc par
exemple au sein de l'éducation nationale
on essaye d'intervenir dans les collèges
dans les lycées directement pour
présenter l'apprentissage c'est marrant
ce collège en hauteur comme ça bon jour
pour moi c'est très important que chaque
élève et l'information qu'il sache qu'il
un choix dans la poursuite de ses études
soit la voie scolaire classique soit
l'apprentissage et du coup un jeune qui
décidé d'arrêter l'école rapidement
finalement va choisir de continuer de
faire après un bac + 2 à bac +3 et c'est
parce que vraiment il va il va retrouver
de la motivation et du sens à ces études
couche sur on la suit dans tous ses
déplacements dans dans tous les
événements qu'elle peut créer autour
justement de l'alternance et de
l'apprentissage
et cette dynamique fait que on commence
à pousser les tentes petit à petit ma
des collèges des lycées où
l'apprentissage n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui on a à peu près de 80000
apprentis en tout qui sont donc dans des
cfa dans toute l'île de france
on peut aller du niveau c ap au niveau
bac + 5
sachez que ça se cantonne pas à dc ap on
passe de l'entreprise au centre de
formation et et puis c'est vrai que du
coup c'est un rythme plus soutenu le
salaire il est fixé en fonction de votre
âge
et puis de l'année dans laquelle vous
êtes en formation c'est à dire qu'en
première année de l'apprentissage vous
avez moins de 18 ans vous allez toucher
25 % du smic et vous pouvez dire à vos
parents pour les rassurer il n'est pas
soumis à l'impôt sur le revenu et en
plus les parents conservent leurs droits
aux allocations familiales
bonjour
qui est très très important ça va être
ta posture à toi c'est à dire que tu
dois vraiment être dans une démarche
proactive
donc moi ce que je te conseille de la
première étape à faire donc c'est
d'aller vers le cfa pour après pouvoir
répondre aux questions qu'on va te poser
dans l'entretien en entreprise donc par
exemple le principal pré requis dans
l'apprentissage certes c'est l'âge mais
c'est aussi après il le savoir être le
comportement tant que tu n'as pas signé
ton contralto d'inscription n'est pas
confirmée dans le self on communique pas
assez sur l'intérêt de l'apprentissage
pourtant ça crève les yeux c'est
vraiment une solution miraculeuse pour
pas mal de jeunes qui vont retrouver la
motivation etc
et c'est vraiment ce qui me donne envie
de continuer quoi de pouvoir informer
tout le monde sur l'apprentissage et ses
intérêts de nombreux avantages existent
aussi pour les entreprises afin de les
inciter à recruter en contrat
d'apprentissage encourager les apprentis
à poursuivre leurs études au plus haut
niveau les imprégner de la culture
d'entreprise et ainsi les préparer au
monde du travail
tel est le fer de lance de la société
thyssenkrupp matérial france
[Musique]
vous êtes ici amoureux pas au siège de
thyssen krupp matérial france
le premier distributeur d'aciers
spéciaux et métaux non ferreux du groupe
allemand thyssen krupp et guay des
matériaux variés des services de
transformation mais également de
parachèvement à destination des plus
grosses industries 720 collaborateurs à
travers la france et 300 personnes sur
le site de maurepas ou quinze apprentis
répartis dans des services comme les
ressources humaines l'informatique
hygiène sécurité environnement la
finance ou le commercial s'était passé
commence maintenant
alors écoute il a vraiment des
compétences avancées sur la partie hse
il n'y a pas de souci une bonne
expérience professionnelle
on a un panel de recrutement possible
sur des cursus variées qui vont du bep
bac pro au bac + 5
on est sans arrêt nous en train de
chercher des écoles qui pourrait
proposer les cursus que nous recherchons
aujourd'hui celle inverse pour voudrais
c'est que ces écoles viennent à nous
c'est vraiment dans cet esprit là on se
cale avec notre stratégie tkmf 20 sur la
recherche de nouveaux talents hse
qualité marketing commerce de nombreux
services recrutent chez ti ciel et sur
une note de service
il faut que tu te met à la portée des
gens sains fuyarde barbara elle a choisi
les ressources humaines
ça s'est très très bien passé durant les
deux entretiens je suis resté moi même
déjà ce qui est important je leur ai
expliqué mon parcours et ils ont bien
aimé la façon dont j'ai valoriser mon
expérience on a beaucoup de choses à
développer ce qui apporte beaucoup de
matière pour son apport personnel au
niveau de mes compétences
et oui les jeunes ont bien compris
l'intérêt de l'apprentissage notamment
dans le supérieur
chaque année j'ai changé l'entreprise ça
m'a permis de découvrir différents
secteurs d'activité et je dirais que
chez thyssen j'ai pu découvrir
l'industrie
un domaine que je connaissais pas
auparavant le but ça va être d'éviter
des accidents de travail donc pour cela
on va au quotidien informer et
sensibiliser les salariés aux risques
qu'elles y sont exposés l'objectif ça va
être de vérifier que nos collaborateurs
travaillent avec un éclairement
suffisant pour être dans de bonnes
conditions
on a quatre machines on va faire quatre
machines là ça me paraît bien
nature et l'autre tu sais ça lorsqu'on
réalise une action on sait qu'on a
quelqu'un qui nous épaulent à côté qui
va nous dire ce qui est bien ce qui est
améliorée j'essaye de faire une remise
en question perpétuelle vis-à-vis de mon
travail
6 alternant en 2014 10 en 2015 et 15 en
la courbe des contrats en alternance n'a
cessé de croître ces trois dernières
années chez thyssen une évolution que la
société souhaite faire perdurer pour la
rentrée 2010 est en gagnant davantage de
visibilité auprès des jeunes
grâce à une diversification des
partenariats avec les centres de
formation du territoire
cet apprenti sur dix sont embauchés à
l'issue de leur formation et 75 % des
diplômés bénéficient d'un contrat en cdi
dans les trois ans l'apprentissage s'est
résolument un gage d'expérience qui
suscite la confiance des entreprises une
porte ouverte sur le monde du travail
encouragé par la mise en place des aides
en faveur des étudiants de leur famille
mais aussi des entreprises
les rencontres de l'apprentissage se
dérouleront le mercredi 26 avril à la
maison de l'étudiant
au programme découverte des métiers du
ceap et au masters pour les chefs
d'entreprises des tpe pme
venez à l'atelier organisé par l'apec à
skis cube sur le thème du recrutement
le 27 avril à guyancourt découvrez
ensuite un zoom métier à la cité des
métiers attrape les 19 25 et 26 avril
prochains rendez vous les mercredis 19
et 26 avril au cfa d'afida et d'alter
pro pour leur journée portes ouvertes
mais aussi au forum des jobs d'été et de
l'apprentissage ainsi que celui de
l'alternance
les 3 et 11 mai prochains voilà
l'apprentissage n'a plus de secret pour
vous en attendant le prochain numéro de
mode d'emploi portez vous bien
oui
[Musique]
à